so your group at mit
is trying to understand the molecular
basis of human disease
what are some of the biggest challenges
in your view don't
get me started i mean irregularities any
human disease
is the most complex challenge
in modern science so because human
disease
is as complex as the human genome
it is as complex as the human brain
and it is in many ways even more complex
because the more we understand disease
complexity
the more we start understanding genome
complexity and
epigenome complexity and brain circuitry
complexity
and immune system complexity and cancer
complexity and so forth
so traditionally
human disease was following basic
biology
you would basically understand basic
biology and model organisms
like you know mouse and fly and yeast
you would understand sort of mammalian
biology
and animal biology and eukaryotic
in sort of progressive layers of
complexity
getting closer to human phylogenetically
and you would do perturbation
experiments in those species
to see if i knock out a gene what
happens
and based on the knocking out of these
genes you would basically then have a
way to drive
human biology because you would you
would sort of understand the functions
of these genes and then if you find that
a human gene
locus something that you've mapped from
human genetics
to that gene is related to a particular
human disease you say ha
now i know the function of the gene from
the model organisms
i can now go and understand the function
of that gene
in human but this is all changing this
is dramatically changed so that that was
the old way of doing basic biology you
would start with the animal models the
eukaryotic models
the mammalian models and then you would
go to human
human genetics has been so transformed
in the last
decade or two that human genetics is now
actually driving the basic biology
there is more genetic mutation
information
in the human genome than there will ever
be in any other species
what do you mean by mutation information
so so perturbations is how you
understand
systems so an engineer builds systems
and then they know how they work from
the inside out a scientist
study systems through perturbations you
basically say if i poke that balloon
what's going to happen and i'm going to
film it in super high resolution
understand i don't know
aerodynamics or fluid dynamics if it's
filled with water etc so you can then
make experimentation by perturbation and
then the scientific process is sort of
building models that
best fit the data design new experiments
that best test your models and challenge
your models and so forth
that's the same thing with science
basically if you're trying to understand
biological science
you basically want to do perturbations
that then drive
the models so how do these perturbations
allow you to understand
disease so if if you know that
a gene is related to disease you don't
want to just know that it's related to
the disease
you want to know what is the disease
mechanism because you want to
go and intervene so the way that i like
to describe it is that
traditionally epidemiology
which is basically the study of disease
you know sort of the observational study
of disease
has been about correlating one thing
with another thing
so if you if you have a lot of people
with liver disease who are also
alcoholics
you might say well maybe the alcoholism
is driving the liver disease
or maybe those who have liver disease
self-medicate with alcohol
so that the connection could be either
way
with genetic epidemiology it's about
correlating changes in the genome
with phenotypic differences and then you
know the direction of causality
so if you know that a particular gene is
related
to the disease you can basically say
okay perturbing that gene in mouse
causes the mice to have x phenotype
so perturbing that gene in human causes
the humans to have the disease
so i can now figure out what are the
detailed molecular phenotypes
in the human that are related to that
organismal
phenotype in the disease so it's all
about understanding
disease mechanism understanding what are
the pathways what are the tissues
what are the processes that are
associated with the disease so that we
know how to intervene
you can then prescribe particular
medications that also alter these
processes
you can prescribe lifestyle changes that
also affect these processes
and so forth there's such a beautiful
puzzle to try to solve
like what kind of perturbations
eventually have this ripple effect that
leads to disease
across the population and then you study
that for animals
or mice first and then see how that
might possibly connect to
humans how hard is that puzzle of
trying to figure out how little
perturbations might lead
to in a stable way to a disease
in animals we make the puzzle
simpler because we perturb one gene at a
time
that's the beauty of is the power of
animal models you can basically
decouple the perturbations you only do
one perturbation
and you only do strong perturbations at
a time
in human the puzzle is incredibly
complex
because i mean obviously you don't do
human experimentation
you wait for natural selection and
natural genetic variation
to basically do its own experiments
which it has been doing for hundreds
and thousands of years in the human
population
and for hundreds of thousands of years
across
you know the the history leading to the
human population
so you basically take this natural
genetic variation that we all carry
within us
every one of us carries six million
perturbations
so i've done six million experiments on
you six million experiments for me
six plus million experiments on every
one of seven billion people on the
planet what's the six million correspond
to
six million unique genetic variants
that are segregating the human
population every one of us
carries millions of polymorphic
sites poly many morph forms polymorphic
means many forms
variants that basically means that every
one of us has
single nucleotide alterations that we
have inherited from moment from that
that basically can be thought of as tiny
little perturbations
most of them don't do anything but some
of them
lead to all of the phenotypic
differences that we see
between us the reason why two twins are
identical is because
these variants completely determine the
way that i'm going to look
at exactly 93 years of age how happy are
you with this kind of data set
is it uh large enough of
the human population of earth is that
too big too small
yeah so so the the is it is it large
enough
is a power analysis question and in
every one of our grants we do a power
analysis
based on what is the effect size that i
would like to detect
and what is the natural variation
in the two forms so every time you do a
perturbation you're asking i'm changing
form a into foreign b
form a has some natural genetic some
natural phenotypic variation around it
and form b has some natural phenotypic
variation around it
if those variances are large and the
differences between the mean of a and
the mean of b
are small then you have very little
power the further the means go apart
that's the effect size the more power
you have
and the smaller the standard deviation
the more power you have
so basically when you're asking is that
sufficiently large
certainly not for everything but we
already have enough power
for many of the stronger effects
in the more tight distributions so
that's a hopeful message that
there exists parts of the genome
that have a strong effect that has a
small
variants that's exactly right
unfortunately
those perturbations are the basis of
disease in many cases
so it's not a you know hopeful message
sometimes it's a terrible message
it's basically well some people are sick
but if when
if we can figure out what are these
contributors to sickness
we can then help make them better and
help many other people better
who don't carry that exact mutation but
who carry
mutations on the same pathways
and that's what we like to call the
allelic series of a gene
you basically have many perturbations
of the same gene in different people
each with a different
frequency in the human population and
each with a different effect
on the individual charism so you said in
the past
there would be these small experiments
on perturbations and animal models
what does this puzzle solving process
look like today so we basically have
you know something like seven billion
people in the planet and every one of
them carries something like six million
mutations you basically have an enormous
matrix of genotype
by phenotype by systematically measuring
the phenotype of these individuals and
the traditional way of measuring this
phenotype has been to look at
one trait at a time you would gather
families
and you would sort of paint the
pedigrees of
a strong effect what we like to call
mendelian
mutation so a mutation that gets
transmitted in a dominant or a recessive
but strong effect form where basically
one locus
plays a very big role in that disease
and you could then look at carriers
versus non-carriers
in one family carries versus
non-carriers in another family
and do that for hundreds sometimes
thousands of families
and then trace these inheritance
patterns and then figure out what is the
gene
that plays that role is this the matrix
that you're showing
in in talks or lectures so
that matrix is the input
to the stuff that i saw in talks so
basically that matrix has traditionally
been strong effect
genes what the matrix looks like now is
instead of pedigrees instead of families
you basically have thousands and
sometimes
hundreds of thousands of unrelated
individuals
each with all of their genetic variants
and each with their
phenotype for example height or lipids
or you know whether they're sick or not
for a particular trait
that has been the modern view instead of
going to families
going to unrelated individuals with one
phenotype at a time
and what we're doing now as we're
maturing in all of these sciences
is that we're doing this in the context
of large medical systems
or enormous cohorts that are very well
phenotyped across
hundreds of phenotypes sometimes with
our complete electronic health record
so you can now start relating not just
one gene segregating one family
not just thousands of variants
segregating with one phenotype
but now you can do millions of variants
versus hundreds of phenotypes
and as a computer scientist i mean
deconvolving that matrix partitioning it
into the layers of biology
that are associated with every one of
these elements
is a dream come true it's it's like the
world's greatest puzzle and you can now
solve that puzzle by throwing in
more and more knowledge about the
function of different genomic regions
and how these functions are changed
across tissues
and in the context of disease and that's
what my group and many other groups are
doing
we're trying to systematically relate
this genetic variation
with molecular variation at the
expression level
of the genes at the epigenomic level
of the gene regulatory circuitry and at
the cellular level
of what are the functions that are
happening in those cells at the single
cell level
using single cell profiling and then
relayed all that
vast amount of knowledge computationally
with the thousands of traits that each
of these
of thousands of variants are perturbing
i mean this is something we talked about
i think last time
so there's these effects at different
levels that happen you said at a single
cell level you're trying to see things
that
happened due to certain perturbations
and then
so it's not just like a puzzle of um
perturbation and disease it's
perturbation
effect then a cellular level then at an
organ level
a body like how do you
disassemble this into like what your
group is working on
you're basically taking a bunch of the
hard problems in the space
how do you break apart a difficult
disease
and break it apart into problems that
you into puzzles that you can now start
solving
so there's a struggle here computer
scientists love hard puzzles
and they're like oh i want to you know
build a method that just deconvolves the
whole thing computationally
and you know that's very tempting and
it's very appealing
but biologists just like to decouple
that complexity experimentally to just
like peel off layers of complexity
experimentally
and that's what many of these modern
tools that you know my group and others
have
both developed and used the fact that we
can now
figure out tricks for peeling off these
layers of complexity by testing
one cell type at a time or by testing
one cell
at a time and you could basically say
what is the effect of this genetic
variant associated with alzheimer's
on human brain human brain
sounds like oh it's an organ of course
just go one organ at a time
but human brain has of course dozens of
different brain regions
and within each of these brain regions
dozens of different cell types
and every single type of neuron every
single type of glial cell
between astrocytes oligodendrocytes
microglia
between you know all of the neural cells
and the vascular cells
and the immune cells that are
co-inhabiting the the brain between the
different types of
excitatory and inhibitory neurons that
are sort of interacting with each other
between different layers
of neurons in the cortical layers every
single one of these
has a different type of function
to play in cognition in
interaction with the environment in
maintenance
of the brain in energetic needs
in feeding the brain with blood with
oxygen
in clearing out the debris that are
resulting from the super high energy
production of cognition in in humans
so all of these things are basically
um potentially deconvolvable
computationally
but experimentally you can just do
single cell profiling
of dozens of regions of the brain across
hundreds of individuals
across millions of cells and then now
you have
pieces of the puzzle that you can then
put back together
to understand that complexity
i mean first of all i mean the human
brain the cells in the human brain are
the most
okay maybe i'm romanticizing it but
cognition seems to be very complicated
so uh separating into the the function
breaking alzheimer's down to
the cellular level seems very
challenging
is that basically you're trying to find
a way that
some perturbation and genome
results in some obvious
major dysfunction in the cell
you're trying to find something like
that exactly so so
what does human genetics do human
genetics basically looks at the whole
path
from genetic variation all the way to
disease
so human genetics has basically taken
thousands
of alzheimer's cases
and thousands of controls matched for
age for
sex for you know environmental
backgrounds and so forth and then looked
at that map
where you're asking what are the
individual genetic perturbations
and how are they related to all the way
to alzheimer's disease
and that has actually been quite
successful so we now have
you know more than 27 different loci
these are genomic regions
that are associated with alzheimer's at
this
end-to-end level but the moment you sort
of
break up that very long path into
smaller levels
you can basically say from genetics what
are the
epigenomic alterations at the level of
gene regulatory elements
where that genetic variant perturbs the
control region nearby
that effect is much larger you mean
much larger in terms of this down the
line impact or it's much larger in terms
of the
measurable effect this a versus b
variance
is actually so much cleanly defined when
you go to the shorter branches
because for one genetic variant to
affect alzheimer's
that's a very long path that basically
means that in the context of millions of
these six million variants that every
one of us carries
that one single nucleotide has a
detectable effect
all the way to the end i mean it's just
mind-boggling that that's even possible
but indeed yeah but indeed there are
such effects
so the hope is or the most
scientifically speaking the
the most effective place where to detect
the alteration that results in diseases
earlier on in the pipeline as early as
possible
it's it's a trade-off if you go very
early on in the pipeline
now each of these epigenomic alterations
for example this enhancer control region
is active maybe 50 less which is a
dramatic effect
now you can ask well how much does
changing one regulatory region in the
genome
in one cell type change disease well
that path is now long
so if you instead look at expression
the path between genetic variation the
expression of one gene goes through many
enhancer regions and therefore it's a
subtler effect at the gene level
but then now you're closer because one
gene is acting
on you know in the context of only 20
000 other genes
as opposed to one enhancer acting in the
context of two million other enhancers
so you basically now have genetic
epigenomic the circuitry
transcriptomic the gene expression level
and then cellular where you can
basically say i can measure
various properties of those cells what
is the calcium
influx rate when i have this genetic
variation
what is the synaptic density what is the
electric
impulse conductivity and so on so forth
so you can measure things along this
path to disease and you can also measure
endo phenotypes you can basically
measure
you know um your brain activity you can
do
imaging in the brain you can basically
measure i don't know the heart rate the
pulse the lipids
the amount of blood secreted and so
forth
and then through all of that you can
basically get
at the path to causality the path to
disease
you